uh tom cruise you're here tonight to
tell us about top gun maverick yes and
yeah yeah
this is exciting because it's over 30
years it's a long time five years 35
years a long time coming how did it
happen now when do the stars align
for years the studios wanted me to do it
and
audiences have wanted me to do it i've
gone around the world and there was just
a moment where
[Music]
you know jerry brookheimer wanted to do
it and
he came to me we were talking about it
and that we just came up with some
good ideas and
it was just that moment i thought if i'm
going to ever do this now's the time and
i've been lucky enough to see it thank
you very much for organizing that and it
is we've sold on the imax it is
incredible it's like you're in the
plains it's amazing but equally it's all
new and you know all bells and whistles
but there are lots of uh references to
the old one like you know the die hard
fans will love it little seeds there
little things new but yeah some easter
eggs and you've brought us some footage
because this is you know there's no
green right there's no green screen is
there in this thing no you know what it
was i mean the first time that i did it
one of the reasons you know i've loved
aviation my whole life and i was like i
want to make this but i want to be able
to film in the f-14
so with this one technology we can
really do a lot of flying now in it and
so i had to create a whole training
program for the pilots we had to develop
the cameras for to be able to fly in the
f-18s i went and talked to the defense
department and the head of the navy and
they they gave us permission to fly in
the aircraft it was it's really very
interesting because i not only had to
kind of create a program for the actors
to understand become pilots
but also had to teach them about editing
and lighting and the fighter pilots to
teach them about filming
it was just like creating these cameras
creating you know and really put the
audience in a position where they feel
like they're the fighter pilots and you
know and you really do i miss you guys
we miss you i wish you were there i know
my gosh i wish you guys were here acting
with tom cruise a dream or was i got an
added pressure how was it
um both actually uh i mean it was
extraordinary it was such a privilege um
i had such a great time i did things
that i've never done before and who do
you who do you play in the movie
jennifer i play penny benjamin an old
friend of mavericks there she is
on her very cool car wow and mars tells
you the character you play is kind of
the big connection to the to the first
movie yeah so i play i play goose's kid
and uh are we allowed to say that oh
yeah
maybe you think we are yeah yeah you are
you know yes you can it's out now yeah
yeah yeah so uh
that's a joke right that's his that's
all
that's out yeah but yeah so so i play
his his kid and uh obviously there's
some history there with with mavericks
so i think i think it's really wonderful
you know and tom i had such a you know
pleasure working with him and everybody
in the cast and you know the film's
phenomenal uh not to depress anyone but
miles wasn't born when the first top gun
came out so uh
had you seen the first top gun yeah
absolutely and i told tom he's been he's
been waiting my entire life to to work
with me literally
and miles tell me this when you signed
up for this did you know that there
wouldn't be green screen did you know
that this was all going to be proper
g-force and and real
um
yeah i think that was i think that was
in the street
i think that was
a fine print somewhere in the fine print
somewhere
no i mean i i did i did absolutely but i
i
absolutely underestimated
the training that it would take to be
able to withstand
um you know the g forces that we're you
know pulling you know people are
throwing up you know in the cockpit
fairly often like it is it is no joke to
getting those jets and we're making top
gun you know so we're never going around
sightseeing so with this one technology
we can really do a lot of flying now in
it and so i had to create a whole
training program for the pilots we had
to develop the cameras for to be able to
fly in the f-18s i went and talked to
the defense department and the head of
the navy and they they gave us
permission to fly in the aircraft it was
it's really very interesting because i
not only had to kind of create a program
for the actors to understand become
pilots
but also had to teach them about editing
and lighting and the fighter pilots to
teach them about filming it was just
like creating these cameras creating you
know and really put the audience in a in
a position where they feel like they're
the fighter pilots it's it's very
intense like what miles said i told you
i said and i shot the early test i i
showed you the early tests you might
have you might have whispered in two
years how many times did i say
i told you
i said and i even shot first and i
showed you the footage show me the email
you know what i never taught i was
afraid to tell
tom at the time was i had just recently
come out of sort of like decided to out
think my
think myself out of a really crippling
fear of flying that i suffered from for
years
and so originally when i signed on to do
the movie there was no flying from my
character my character was on land she
was on the water she was never in the
air there was a scene at at one point
where we were it's like on taxing on a
runway maybe
in a plane together so tom and i are
shooting that scene
and the plane the p51 it's like tiny
you're like the top of the cockpit is
right here my knees are up against his
back and
he's like wow you ever jenna have you
ever been in a in a plane like this
before i was like no no i i haven't tom
it's amazing
he's like ever done
[Laughter]
very elegant just some very elegant
rolls you know it's gonna be nice and
easy
so yeah that's how i found out that i
was gonna be up in the p-51 with tom
flying it
tell us something yeah
no tell us everything yes
we got the picture i think they've
released this picture look how happy you
were
[Applause]
that's not a day at work you're like yay
look at me
it's so much fun are you inside are you
uh i'm not a pilot i'm a sailor oh yeah
navy girl i'm a sailor i used to race
boats in the film i can give you that we
have a sailing scene okay what a sailing
scene that's right yes is there like a
second song on the boat maybe that you
and tom get down like a sexy theme song
yeah like if there is a theme song
no that's not a sexy one
there's gonna be i think there's there
might be yeah there's gonna definitely
be a sexy theme song is the boat rocky
i'll tell you what it is is the boat
rocking yeah guys come on this is too
much no i'm gonna know
tell anybody
no one watches this well just
i almost believed
is going to want to see this movie and i
for one am going to be right in the
front of the line i cannot wait to see
it it's going to be so awesome yes
the trials of being in one of those jets
i mean it's horrific or would you be
better now because you know because i
fly aerobatics now but when you first
start flying you're gonna you get sick
you know you're like properly sick yeah
properly like fill a bag sick you know
i know the first day
when uh yeah you know you've flown in
yeah yeah but you get really sick yeah
you know i flew with the blue angels and
then i went when we were filming i kind
of my deal was when i made my deal i
said i've got to fly in the f-14 i made
it with the studio
and i had to be filmed in the f-14
live
and uh so i had to go through all the
ejector seat training and i couldn't
wait to fly so in the morning
i saw the first pilot that i flew with
uh his name was bozo
and uh yeah
gives you confidence yes
hi how are you bozo bozo
and we were up there we had five minutes
of film and we had to turn you know we
had to coordinate he and i and we had
other airplanes coming in on us and
there was air combat maneuvers and we
very detailed briefings and everything
so we're going out and we're just right
you know i don't know a couple feet off
the deck in the desert and we're just
sweating i'm sweating in the f-14
and uh because we were doing heavy
maneuvers and we did a really heavy
maneuver we pulled like nine and a half
g's and i you know you go out you got a
g-suit on but you you know you just kind
of black out and i came through it's
like i had my my barf bag right here my
sided thing i was like okay so now i'm
gonna go get it done so i can do the
next take so i leaned down like this
pulled it i was like just went down like
this
and he at that point decided to pull up
and he pulled up so hard and for so long
i i mean i can't do it now my head
literally was touching the ground with
the g-force it expires fine and the
push-to-talk is right here it's going
like this
it's like you know i mean he was going
up forever
so finally he leveled off and i just i
had the bag of my hand i was like i said
bozo
[Laughter]
what's didn't you see i like you get a
check you didn't tell me you were going
to do that my head was like what he says
yeah they don't call me bozo for nothing
[Music]
you